Grazie e dato che il tema è radici vi
vorrei parlare di qualcosa di un po'
particolare perché
Montalcino è famoso Essenzialmente per
quello che si pensa sia un legame molto
forte con le sue radici ed è vero
però sono radici che
forse non vengono davvero per comprese
per quello che sono Montalcino è
qualcosa di particolare probabilmente la
comunità agricola più ricca del mondo
cioè Ovvero la comunità che riesce a
trarre dal suo territorio dalla sua
agricoltura il maggior reddito pro
capite è una comunità che ha un
benessere molto diffuso non ha grandi
ricchi ha molti benestanti ma dove nasce
Tutto questo perché è tutto questo
Beh nasce da un rapporto curioso con la
sua storia che è molto Toscano la
Toscana in fondo cos'è
è un territorio che non ha fiumi
importanti
non apporti importanti non ha pianure
ricche è un territorio che naturalmente
è molto povero però è sempre stato molto
ricco perché
un po' per l'ingegno dei suoi abitanti
un po' per un genio particolare diciamo
un carattere particolare della sua
cultura che è quello di saper creare
tradizioni la tradizione è un po' cos'è
la tradizione è una novità È un qualcosa
di nuovo che ha avuto successo e si è
ripetuto così tanto tempo da divenire
usuale e a quel punto diventa tradizione
il problema delle tradizioni è che
spesso si sedimentano Allora si crea una
cosa bella funziona è un bellissimo
risultato e poi cominciamo a
prendere la non per ciò che Ma per la
forma che assume
confondiamo la forma con la sostanza E
allora pensiamo alla tradizione sia
mettiamo
[Musica]
arare il campo con i Bovi
e seminarlo con le mani Beh non è quello
la tradizione è produrre grano o
produrre uva non di usare il cavallo il
carro il bove la tecnica tecnologia
cambia la tecnica cambia usiamo il
trattore ma quello che facciamo è la
sostanza questo è Montalcino Montalcino
e diciamo il simbolo di come un modo di
capire intendere la tradizione ha
portato il benessere e lo ha riportato
varie volte perché questa è una comunità
particolare una comunità che è stata è
nata lungo una strada è nata mille anni
fa lungo la strada più importante della
cristianità strada che andava a Roma La
strada è stata per un millennio la
strada più transitata del mondo
occidentale lungo quella strada è
diventato un porto di mare perché senza
mare perché di qui passava di tutto e
passando di tutto si è dovuta adattare a
ciò che passava e ha creato il benessere
con questo benessere basato su molte
cose diverse in passato si era talmente
benestante e si è comprata l'esenzione
dalle tasse dalla Repubblica di Siena
e per molti anni è stato un grande Porto
Franco Di conseguenza sviluppato in due
attività manifatturiere attività di
trasformazione di Commercio poi le cose
sono cambiate a un certo punto questa
via sia essiccata perché la Repubblica
Italiana ha inventato l'Autostrada del
Sole da un giorno all'altro i milioni di
persone erano 4/5 milioni all'anno che
passavano da qua non passavano più
e Montalcino si è reinventata come aveva
fatto in passato dopo i suoi 5 assedi
dopo essere stato distrutta ricostruita
dopo i vari problemi che ha avuto se ero
inventata Come ha preso una delle sue
tradizioni storie quel Brunello che ha
500 anni di storia documentata e che è
stato a momenti vino direi vino
importante pensate era il vino di corte
di Guglielmo III d'Orange che quando era
un giovane principe spesso era andato a
Roma e si era innamorato del Brunello
diventato re d'Inghilterra ne fece il
suo vino di corte è stato il vino di
molti Papi è stato un vino famosissimo
poi a periodi di dimenticanza periodo di
ritornato quando è scoppiata la miseria
un gruppo di montaggi cinesi ha pensato
di riprendere questa tradizione e farne
un punto di forza
ed è stato un enorme successo è stata
enorme successo perché hanno ripensato
alle radici di questa tradizione e hanno
dimenticato il modo come si faceva ci
hanno portato avanti la sostanza e
buttato via la forma la forma era un
vino che veniva venduto a chi passava ai
ricchi agli importanti ai Principi ai
reni alle persone potevano spendere
passavano in quantità da Montalcino
e veniva fatto per loro bene è stato
preso questo vino per i re e per i
principi per i papi per le persone
importanti e lo si è portato in giro per
il mondo per poterlo vendere per poter
essere ciò che era abbiamo deciso di
andare noi e abbiamo inventato un modo
di commerciarlo
mio nonno ebbe un'idea geniale disse
tutti
pagavano gli agenti di vino il 3%, noi
avevamo il vino più caro d'Italia perché
non pagargli il 15 e così a un certo
punto da un giorno all'altro trovo come
i suoi agenti i migliori agenti d'Italia
suo cugino
era un grandissimo enologo forse
Sicuramente il più grande della Toscana
nei suoi tempi e uno dei più grandi
d'Italia andando in giro per eventi per
clienti per tutto portava i suoi vini li
presentava e li vendeva andando Porta a
porta quasi se vogliamo Ecco ambedue le
cose Loro le hanno espanse le hanno
condivise con la comunità dei loro
colleghi è diventato usuale e poi il
modo di essere il modo di fare l'unicità
quella l'abbiamo conservata avevamo
l'unico grande Sangiovese in purezza
d'Italia
in un mondo del vino che correggeva
tutto
se un vino era un po' debole in
quell'anno ci aggiungeva qualcosa di
dava forza se mancava colore aggiungeva
qualcosa per il colore Noi no Noi
facevamo una pietra e purezza Noi
facevamo un qualcosa di unico
o era perfetto o non era che era il
brunello questa nostra unicità l'abbiamo
mantenuta
vi devo dire Istintivamente vi devo dire
studiatamente Non lo so
so che questo spirito di capire il senso
È una tradizione e portarla avanti
ignorando le varie forme e l'avevano
irrigidita nel tempo è stato un enorme
successo Questa è la ricetta di
Montalcino Queste sono le radici il modo
di comprenderle le radici di una
comunità che si è forgiata nei secoli su
una strada una unità che si è incrociata
con la strada di conseguenza mettiamo È
una serie vescovile a 18 chiese dentro
le mura ma anche una chiesa protestante
ce l'ha da secoli aveva una fiorente
comunità ebraica con tanto di persone
famosissime pensate i Levi di Montalcino
sono i Levi Montalcini la famiglia della
Rita Levi Montalcini Premio Nobel ha una
moschea ha un Blend culturale
incredibile attualmente perché perché
l'ha sempre avuto una comunità che ha
saputo ibridarsi mantenendo ciò che è
questo è un po' Il segreto della Toscana
saper fare il nuovo saperlo fare
continuativamente
saperlo reinventare e ricreare se voi
Guardate la Toscana di oggi
questa zona questa Val d'Orcia Voi
vedete una zona bellissima patrimonio
dell'Unesco
un'icona bene questa icona È una
tradizione nuova se voi foste venuti in
questa icona un secolo e mezzo fa
Voi avreste visto Calanchi terreni
coltivabili addirittura avevamo abbiamo
tuttora un deserto l'unico deserto
d'Italia deserto anche Roma e zone
assolutamente non coltivabili
nell'Ottocento i nostri avi usando il
meglio della tecnologia che c'era cioè
gli esplosivi di allora perché ancora
non c'erano Ovviamente nei trattori del
ruspe hanno trasformato questi Calanchi
queste zone incoltivabili Le dolci
colline della Val dolce le trovate una
traccia nel museo del paesaggio di San
Quirico una cosa bellissima
Andate a vedere alcune delle icone
attuali
mettiamo la bellissima Chiesina di
vitaleta un'icona fotografata da tutti
bene è Sì è vero È una chiesa del
Cinquecento ma è stata totalmente
rifatta fino a 800 Nel suo aspetto
attuale Dunque è una a poco a meno di un
secolo
ed è un'icona della Toscana della
Toscana questi lunghi viali di cipressi
e voi volete che voi Vedete che
identificate a una Toscana sono solo
Fiorentini fino a poche decine di anni
fa li trovavate solo a Firenze a Siena
non c'erano tutte le altre parti della
Toscana non c'erano bene Sono un'icona
sono la storia sono la Toscana la
Toscana di sempre
però ci sono solo ora vedete noi toscani
abbiamo un'arte di saper capire cos'è
Cosa sono le radici saperle usare
saperle vivere e saperle rinnovare la
Toscana è il rinnovamento e le radici le
radici eterne Noi abbiamo una terra
povera e ci siamo dovuti ingegnare
Questo è un po' il lascito l'eredità
della Toscana
all'umanità per dirla un po' in termini
di roboanti A dire il vero un po'
eccessivi per me è anche vero è un
piccolo angolo del mondo e contiene una
parte a prodotto una parte importante
dell'arte della cultura della
letteratura
e di tante altre cose alcune che manco
mai vi immaginereste tipo mettiamo voi
andate in banca
Penso che tutti voi Più o meno lo usate
Beh la banca come la concepiamo ora è
nata a Siena i nostri antenati mille
anni fa avevano il problema di avere un
prodotto molto bello che è una loro Lane
e dove Le vendevano non localmente non
c'era mercato Le portavano fino alle
Fiandre Il problema era come portare le
lane era banale ma come riportare
indietro i soldi e quello era un
problema e allora si inventarono la
cambiale portavano una carta
invece di portare i soldi e così non
venivano derubati e cominciarono sto
servizio funzionava così bene lo usarono
per tutti e inventarono una nuova
tradizione un nuovo modo di essere
questo è lo spirito Toscano la cambiale
il mutuo il prestito incredibilmente poi
associate Siena all'arte Beh Siena e
l'inventore della banca chi lo direbbe
mai vedete è una terra
inaspettata dove tanto è nato tanto si
crea e tanto si crea in continuazione è
un modo di essere un modo di essere
estremamente inclusivo estremamente così
forte in se stesso da non avere paura
dell'altro
una cultura in essere e in divenire che
per questo non diventa mai vecchia
Questo è un po' il messaggio È un luogo
come Montalcino che è vissuto per la sua
intera storia di Commercio Commercio
lungo una strada
è vissuto essendo che era un incrocio di
transumanza perché qui si incrocia la
strada che va a Roma con una delle due
strade che vanno da mare a mare in
Toscana
da qui si va a Grosseto cioè si va al
mar Tirreno dall'altro lato si va a
Perugia e poi si scavalca si va
Adriatico l'altro passaggio è la valle
dell'Arno in Croce a Firenze la
geografia detta un po' il modo di essere
Ebbene questa comunità che è nata
nell'incrocio di transumanza dove qui
passavano il bestiame per andare in
Maremma di conseguenza
industrie di coach di concia del pellame
di tutte delle scarpe
tutta una parte di Montalcino che è
totalmente vuota ancora nel centro dove
c'era tutte le vasche da acconciare le
pelli
perché si conciavano queste pelli questi
animali e passavano a volte morivano e
tutta un'industria non esiste più
avevamo con tutte le prese l'industria
delle ceramiche il mattone Forato è
un'invenzione dei crocchi nel 1830 è un
brevetto montalcinose prima il mattone
era compatto è stato inventato qua il
mattone Forato
in questo piccolo comunità curiose è
stata la prima vera la corrente
elettrica in Toscana un mese prima di
Firenze e la terza vero un cinema e lo
spirito e il modo di essere curiosamente
lo sapete come si chiamava l'industriale
che faceva che fece qui il i primi
mattoni foratiker cognome non
particolarmente Toscano direi Però era
Toscano ed era molto cinese
assorbito assorbito da questo contesto
da questa realtà
per cui direi che se esiste una lezione
che la Toscana e che monta il Cino può
dare in campo di radici e che le radici
vanno evolute con il tempo questo era un
borgo di Borghesi di Borghesi che
commerciavano che producevano la storia
non glie l'ha permesso più
all'improvviso questo Borgo che era su
una strada importante per cui aveva un
passaggio continuo di gente che
consumava è diventato isolato diventato
il posto in mezzo al nulla e oggi E
allora che ha fatto se reinventato
andando per il mondo a vendere
tuttora vedete i 270
imbottigliatori di vino di Brunello di
Montalcino di cui buona parte sono
ragazzi perché questa è una comunità che
lascia moltissime possibilità ai giovani
che usano normalmente tutti prendere
andare a vendere il loro vino in giro
nessun altro lo fa un pochino hanno
cominciato in tante altre parti ma un
pochino noi lo facciamo tutti è normale
è un modo di essere ci siamo reinventati
e questo dovrà fare normale questo ora
parla una tradizione Certo che lo è ma
una tradizione nuova è un'evoluzione di
un modo di essere che ha finito per fare
la storia
Questo è l'insegnamento E da questo
territorio riguardo le radici le radici
sono importanti Ma le radici devono
essere vive devono essere vive e
continuare a vivere continuare a
produrre continuare a creare
Montalcino e questo è un territorio di
grande storia
e di grandi radici ma di radici che non
sono mai morte li ringrazio
[Applauso]